les ciné c'est ôter les chroniqueurs ont
décidé en hommage à richard linski keita
grands artistes voilà de dessiner des
poux cave sur les vous les uns les
autres au regard des premiers dessins et
s'est trouvé bien de son époux car c'est
hyper bien dessinés à grains via une
montre euros et bracelets qui a été
barrée qui a fait ça une bague qui a
fait ça pas un truc sur fat ou alors
c'est quoi alors manon le un sac
contenant qui aurait revendu une montre
pour récupérer tringle alors qu'il a
fait c'est maintenant c'est pas nous
c'est toi qui paraît ces gars bien c'est
quoi alors ouais c'est quoi c'est bien
c'est l'espèce d'allégories qui parle de
montres du temps et bijoux dénoncer
quelqu'un c'est quoi c'est quoi le scoop
oui c'est quoi le scoop tu parles de qui
ouais lessines bien gênant mais bien
quand même
et donc c'est quoi ils ont été bons dans
leur existence alors oui c'est vraiment
rare habileté tu voulais pas expliquer
quelques a pas d'histoire
non non vous comprenez est ce que tu
peux nous raconter l'histoire quant à
rencontrer l'homme alors c'est à dire à
kout non je raconte la suite
non alors réservé c'est quoi alors quand
il a rencontré c'était encore ben oui
j'étais à l'as du falafel non tenues
qu'était mais oui il y était déjà
voilà voilà l'aurais je suis arrivé il
m'a dit bruno vient boire un coup de
téléphone divers qui tu parles je vais
dire par là une copine à ma meuf vadi va
pas cela moi j'ai passé l'a dit madame
il a dû il a dit sperme
[Rires]
elle est bien de faire la première
partie de mon cap sur benjamin castaldi
en fait ce qu'il a voulu dire c'est que
benjamin castaldi a préféré revendre son
alliance que romande ces mondes pour
prendre de l'argent c'est une boutade de
doc gynéco c'est vrai sinon c est ce que
vous avez vendu votre alliance un moment
l'alliance de votre femme
ah non non non à l'une de vos phares
attendu des choses il ya très longtemps
qu'il ne l'attendait pas mais quand
j'étais à la fac mais mais je crois pas
que ce soit ça bah ouais on a tendance à
toujours ta montre donc à la salle alors
regardez alors ça voilà le deuxième
essai là cette personne est ouf factory
est ouest cake dessinée ça c'est moi a
alors pourquoi l'année c'est le
personnage milieu non c'est le rouge
c'est qui est la chroniqueuse qui c'est
bien vous label factory à l'ouest oui en
fait là poucave c'est que isabelle à la
sortie de chaque émission
tu es complètement folle et on a une
vidéo et le prouvera
m
oui beaucoup
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quand ça veut pas sourire tu fais ça je
traverse la tension on va pas tarder à
la poule a est là c'est un psychopathe y
est c'est quoi ça il ya quelqu'un de
muscler jours et des incidents
similaires fait c'est mamie c'est cuit
c'est pourquoi la preuve c'est mathieu
qui en milieu way et qui est donc très
musclé et qui se fait toucher les
clémentines par ses assistants n'ont à
ses assistants de vieux clichés c'est
clémentine à une métaphore jumeaux
clémentine tout sur les bras d'un sac
dans les loges demande alexandre mallet
tous ils peuvent le faire
un rabot c'est qui ça et le qui a
dessiné sa 107 vocable kelly oui oui
c'est quoi ouais bah là comme vous le
remarquez c'est benjamin castaldi
oui il est à la radio voix oui j'ai fait
les miller et micro 7h18 et apparemment
il s'est fait il fait dans studio qui
s'est fait tirer dessus
non c'est bien peu cinq attractions
studio ça nous c'est un point commun
cyril n'a pas fait à l'époque pour des
cachets pour emprisonner la grèce quand
vous mangez du coup le camp ça c'est
vrai ça s'évacue assez régulièrement sa
vie très vite la musique parfois j'ai
une tendance à voir que toute la nuance
j'étais en train terme ont une interview
je me suis dit discrètement je vais
lever une petite faith hill ben j'ai
largué un petit un petit peu sauf que
j'ai très vite compris que ce que
j'avais la gaieté par ap mais plus je
l'aimé des morceaux effet qui
l'interviewé alors je ne serai plus mais
un truc et en plus j'avais un pantalon
blanc et non non c'était très très
gênant parce que j'ai pu et dû partir
j'ai dû partir aux toilettes et en fait
j'ai enlevé mon pantalon j'ai enlevé
font qu'elles sont que j'ai jeté dans la
poubelle voilà je retiens de ce moment
là que rend pas couler
voilà alors tiens c'est qui ça c'est une
blague c'est qui ça tiens ça c'est moi
alors oui c'est quoi alors c'est
benjamin castaldi encore bien relier le
lendemain tout l'argent que vous lui
donnez
ouais ils dépensent way pour organiser
des soirées non très arrosée non très
agitée chez lui aya doc gynéco
s'intéresse à vous dans votre dos avec
tout le personnel de h2o sémard doit non
ré si si si si si je fais des parts ou
d'un joli de lipides
enfin pas dans les parties fines pardon
non mais oh je suppose et phuket quoi
c'est vrai c'est ce qu'on a dit quoi
après enquête
cette eau ni nourriture est qu'il invite
toujours c'est vrai voilà là mais c'est
pas mal ça doit vous inviter tout le
monde pas oui donc je vais pas la même
chose
agression qui a fait ça au hasard au
dessin c'est pas le sexe et alors mais
moi j'en repose c'est la position de mam
et les maillots sait pas dessiner ça
c'est peut-être d'octon donne c'est pas
bien c'est à moi j'ai fait le vrai c'est
pas moi mais ça aurait pu être moi que
j'ai souhaité le départ de mamie visible
avec ses bras on saura qui savent c'est
que ça c'est moi c'est quoi ça alors
c'est qu elle est versée à règle kou kou
kou 2 1 des 2 à ses beaux baba coup de
vis donc à baba pendant la pub vous
voyez ça va bien il ya des gens dans
cette équipe que j'ai surpris en temps
de faire des saloperies dans votre dos
ils sont destinés à vous amène à vous
nuire pour l'année prochaine absolument
et j'ai la preuve en images et cette
personne c'est le fayot jean michel
bérard we are devant il vous fait des
compliments à méthane dont tu ne penses
pas un mot et par derrière qui vous
pourrit votre bureau
jamais tu verras oui c est quoi j'en ai
pas dormi pendant trois jours d'avant